What does it mean to be brave?
Today I'm going to show
you why many of us don't understand the nature of courage, and how you can become more courageous
.  We'll look at history's lessons from
real-
life
events about courage, as well as the
fascinating
neuroscience of what happens in our brains when we are courageous
.    The
philosopher
Aristotle
described courage as one of his fundamental virtues.
I have
long
believed that this is the most important virtue because how can you speak up for a right thing without courage?
How
can you pursue your true ambition?
How can you be a
good
leader, a
parent,
or a good
friend
?  All of these involve
challenges of courage
.  One reason we fail at these
challenges is that
we misunderstand the nature of courage
.
How
can you be brave if you don't even know what courage is?    I
would like to take you back to April 2017
.  Trains come and go in the New York
City
subway
.
Two
trains are
coming to a stop on a platform in the Bronx
.
Through the doors of a train, someone
is taking a video.
It
shows a woman trapped between the doors of a train standing on the other side of the platform.
He is holding a bag
.  His head
is outside the box,
while
his body is
trapped inside
.  He stands motionless
,
trapped
, half
inside,
half
outside,
weak
.
The video is
playing
.  Someone is
walking slowly
.
Another person
comes,
then a
third
person
comes.
No one
seems to be in a hurry.    No
one
noticed the trapped woman
.  No one
helped him.
The camera zooms
out,
then zooms in
.
The seconds are
ticking.
This is
very
difficult to watch
.  It seems to be shouting, "
Do something."
"
Help him."
An Instagram story about the incident
posted the video and
broke the news.    If
you
think your day is going badly, be
glad this isn't happening to you
.  There is someone there that we don't see in the video
.
We did
n't see anyone holding a phone and taking a video
.  If you're shocked to see someone in trouble and
others
walking away without helping
,
what does that
say about you for only recording it on video?
In fact,
help
was on the way.    The
subway
workers were
trying to open the doors
.  But, the
video went
viral
because it
speaks to a big fear we all have.
In a moment of crisis, when
we
are desperate
, when we are
stuck
, will people just
walk past us without even thinking of helping?    Wo
n't they at least not look back?
Psychologists
sometimes call this the
'
bystander
effect'
.
Many people
can help in a situation,
but no one steps
forward
.
Everyone is
waiting for others to come and solve the problem
.  This is how
many
bad
things happen in our world
.    It's
happening openly.    While
the world stands idly by
,
many
atrocities are
happening in human history.
This is a proverb that is wrongly attributed to the Irish politician Edmund Burke.    For
evil to triumph, it is
enough for good people to do nothing.
But every
now and then
we hear a different
kind of
story
.    I
interviewed a woman named Abigail Marsh on my podcast
.  He
told me a story.  Many
years
ago,
Abigail
was studying in college
.  He was visiting his family in Washington state for the summer
vacation
.  One night he
went to dinner with a friend in Seattle.
Around midnight he
began driving back home to Tacoma via Interstate 5.
Yes, this is a
very
busy, heavily
congested
highway.
As Abigail approached the crest of the highway
,
she saw something on the road.
Somehow a
dog was
running across the highway
.  Abigail is an
animal
lover.
He
turned the cart around.
Unfortunately
, I
bumped into it anyway.
My car skidded across
multiple lanes of the highway after hitting a dog and swerving
.
The car
started spinning,
spinning again and again.
Abigail
was completely helpless.    It's
a
miracle he didn't collide with anyone.
Finally, the car stopped on the
fast
lane beyond the top of that overpass, facing
oncoming
traffic
.  It was the
most
terrifying
moment I have ever experienced in my life.
I remember trying repeatedly to restart the car
, but
I
couldn't figure out why the engine wasn't working.
A vehicle
reaches the top of the overpass and
comes straight towards Abigail.    At
the last
second,
the driver
saw him and
pulled away
.
Another car
reaches the top and then
pulls away again at the last minute
.
My car
shook every time those big cars and trucks swerved around my car at the last minute.
I
know one of them will definitely hit me.
Abigail was like the woman trapped on that
subway
train
,
but here the
cars were
speeding towards her
.  It is at this
moment that
something amazing
happens.  A
man appears in his
passenger side
window
.
He tells him, "I
think you need help."
Abigail's
first thought
was to remember the advice her mother had given her
: "
Don't let strangers into your car
."  But as
more
cars
roared across the top of the overpass
,
she
told him she needed help.
He
told her to move to the passenger seat.
He waited for the traffic to slow down,
ran around the car, and
got into the driver's seat.
He
figured out why the car wouldn't start.
It was still in
drive
mode
.  He
put the car into park mode and the engine
started.
Waiting for the traffic to slow down again, he
revved the engine,
made a sudden U-turn on the expressway, and
brought the car to the exit
.
His car
was parked on the roadside in front
.
Yes, I still remember his voice when he
saw me
.  I was
gray,
sweating, and
shaking
.  I felt
very
bad
.  He asked
me, "You'll be
fine,
right? Should I
follow you
home
?"    He
asked.
I said, "
No,
no, I'll be
fine
. I'll
be fine."
You know, I couldn't think straight at that
time
.
To which he said, "
Okay,
take care of yourself
."
Then he
got out of the car,
went to his own car, and
disappeared into the night.  That was the
last time I
saw him
.    She
later pieced
together what had happened, apologizing
.
She
realized that the man, who had come over the top of the expressway, might have seen her stuck in the fast lane.
In a split second, he
decided to stop the car and help
.  That
midnight,
he ran across a six-lane
highway to reach her passenger seat window
.    He
risked his life for the second time when he ran around the car to get into the driver's seat
.    For the
third
time, he accelerated
the engine, made a U-
turn, and
brought Abhipakai safely.  At
the
moment he decided to help,
he did
n't know who his enemy was.  She is
a
stranger to him.
Why did
he have to risk
his life three times to save hers
?
This question
stayed with Abhipappa even after she became a psychologist and neuroscientist
.
She is
very
impressed by people who do courageous and kind things for others
.  She began to research a
certain
group of strange people
.
People like Lucia Lloyd.
Lucia
listened to our podcast episode on 'Non-Directed Kidney Donors'.
These are people who
decide to donate a kidney, not just to their friend or family member
.  To a complete
stranger
.    I
want to ask you about a note she sent
, because
it's one of the best notes we've received in the last ten years of producing the Hidden Brain Podcast.
I
really
liked this chapter about how we can all become more philanthropic
.
I was
deeply
moved by someone's statement that God put us on this earth to help others;    I thought I believed the same thing
.    The
correct answer to how I can become like those people who donate kidneys to strangers is to donate my kidney to a stranger
.
So
I have
already
started those tasks
.  Your
episode may lead me to a
situation where I can save someone's life
.
Why aren't more of us
like Lucia
?
One
answer
is that
many of us are like
Lucia when it comes to those closest to us
.    If
your
child,
sibling,
or
parent
needed a kidney to survive
, wouldn't
you
donate an organ to save them
?  But here's the
thing.  Would you do this for a
friend
?
What would you
do for a coworker?
What would
you do for a stranger?
Most of us
suffer from a phenomenon called social discounting
.
We are very
generous to those closest to us
,
but
our generosity diminishes
significantly when our contact with them decreases even slightly
.  When Abigail
began researching kidney donors with the public interest,
she
discovered something very, very interesting.
They
don't feel much difference between those close to them and strangers.
As Lucia said in a note to me, "
I
think God put us on this earth to help others."
Notice,
he didn't say that God
created us to help those closest to us
.    For people
like Lucia
, the distinction between 'us'
and '
them' doesn't
really
exist.
Such
implausible
philanthropists
think that even people they have never met are worthy of love and compassion
.  In fact, when
Abigail
asked people who had donated kidneys with the public interest why they were donating to a stranger,
the
question itself
seemed meaningless to many.    It's
true that when you have two kidneys, you can live well with one, but
if someone dies without your kidney,
they
think the right decision is to donate it to them
.  Because it
seems so natural and obvious to them,
they
can't understand why others don't make this decision.
Abigail
wanted to know if there was any change in the brains of people who would go to such lengths to help strangers.
He scanned the brains of his
charitable
kidney
donors and
compared them with those of less charitable donors
.
He
found a difference in the area of ​​the brain called the ami gaad la.    It
seems that the most generous people have larger ami gaad locks than others.
Why is that
important?
Well,
Ami גד לא
helps us to recognize the suffering of others.    People who are
more generous
seem to be more sensitive to the pain of others
.  Interestingly,
psychopaths
have small ami גד לאה,
which makes sense when you consider that they
often
fail to recognize the distress of others
.
Now, think about the actions of people who rush to help during a
crisis
.  Those who
jump into turbulent seas to rescue drowning strangers
.  People running into a burning building to save a family trapped inside
.
They are
running towards a dangerous situation where we will all freeze or flee.
These extraordinary
people do
not see strangers as strangers
.  They
see them as their own brothers and sisters
.  Many of us have
a
model in
our minds of what it means to be heroic
.  We get this from the television shows we
watch
and the screen stars we
admire
.
But
in real life,
courage
looks very different.  A few
years
ago,
Cory Booker, the mayor of Newark, New Jersey, was
driving home from work
.  When he arrived at his
street
, he saw his
neighbor's
house
on fire
.  His neighbor was screaming that his
daughter was trapped inside
.
Without thinking, the
mayor rushed into the burning house with his
security
officers
.
Booker
entered the house,
struggled through the smoke,
went to the bedroom where the neighbor's daughter was unconscious, carried her on his
shoulders
, and staggered out through the kitchen, which was already
on fire
.
Burning
embers
fell on him, and
he eventually
came out of the house,
collapsed in the yard, from where
he was
taken to the hospital by ambulance
, suffering from smoke
inhalation and
second-degree
burns to his hands
.    A
later
interview was
conducted with Cory Booker on CBS television
.
He
talked about whether he felt brave when he ran into a burning building.
It was a very
scary
thing, and I wish I could say I felt very brave at the
time
, but to be
honest,
it was terrifying
.
I could
n't see anything except the flames coming from the kitchen.
Yes.    At
that
moment I
thought I was stuck.    I
thought I wouldn't be able to leave.
Cory
Booker, who became a senator from New Jersey, doesn't talk
like John Wick
.
He doesn't act like Tom
Cruise or
Matt Damon
.  He doesn't seem
fearless
.
That's where the
main
point
lies.  In our
minds, we
confuse courage and fearlessness
.  When we are afraid in a difficult
situation
, we
tell ourselves that we are not brave because brave people are not afraid
.  I
cannot say this strongly enough.
That
opinion is
completely
wrong.  That's
not true.
Brave people are
not brave because they are fearless.  They
are courageous because they have expanded their circle of love
.  They
treat strangers like their children or siblings or parents
.
For me,
this is the
best lesson of scientific research on selflessness.    If
you
want to be brave, don't
ask how to reduce fear
.  Ask how to
love more
.
Ask how to love better.    I
would like to tell you my personal story
.  There is
no physical courage involved,
but there is the act of taking a great
risk
.    When
I
finished college, I
received an engineering degree.  I
was ready to pursue an MBA and move toward a life of corporate wealth and success.
But,
I had a
few months
off after college
, which I
spent working at a local newspaper.
I
loved journalism and the joy of sharing ideas and explaining things.    When I
told my parents that I was giving up my engineering degree and going to become a journalist, my
dad was very
worried
.  He was worried about how I would
lead my life
.  I should have been more
scared
,
but at the
time, all
I
could think about was how much I loved interviewing people and writing stories.
As the years passed,
many people
told me that it was a brave thing for me to put aside my college education, skip my MBA, and take a gamble in a field where employment was scarce.
But, the truth
is,
I wasn't brave
.
I
loved what I did so much.
Today, the 'Hitton
Brain'
podcast
receives millions of downloads each month
and is
broadcast on over 400 public radio stations across the United States
.  In 2025 alone,
I toured 16
cities
live
.
Things have
gone well for me,
but not because I am
fearless
.  It's because I discovered something bigger than my
fear
.  Check out the show 'Hitten Brain' on Apple
or
Spotify
wherever you listen to podcasts,
and subscribe to this channel for more insights on how the science of the mind can
help you live a better life
.  I am Shankara
Vedanta.
See you again.